hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the importance of simultaneously
detecting and differentiating
sars kobe 2 and influenza during flu
season
i am jennifer woods of la roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
yelena seemstra
phd senior manager global scientific
communications
thermo fisher scientific yelena will
start us
off by giving an overview of respiratory
viruses
and what we may expect to see this
upcoming flu season
combined with the coping 19 pandemic
followed by
peter freeba phd senior manager
clinical application and marketing
support thermo fisher scientific
who will go into detail of thermo fisher
scientific solution
for testing for multiple viruses at the
same time
yelena you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much um today i would like
to talk about
why is it important to detect and
discriminate
the influenza and science club too
during flu season
so seasonal flu is a contagious
respiratory illness
caused by influenza viruses that
circulate
in all parts of the world and in the
northern hemisphere the flu season
typically occurs in the colder months
of the year with the peak in the number
of infections
usually occurring between december
and february depending on the year
between 3 and 11 of the population in
the us
would suffer from a symptomatic flu
infection
but the large proportion of infected
individuals are actually asymptomatic
um and seasonal flu leads to 140 to 810
000 hospitalizations per year
and also results in 12 to 60 000
deaths per year in the us
the coronavirus disease 2019 or the
colvit19
is an infectious respiratory disease
caused by a novel coronavirus the stars
cove 2
that emerged at the end of 2019
in buchan in china and on march
11 last year the world health
organization
has declared the sars code to outbreak
as a global pandemic
and until today there has been more than
188 million confirmed cases
worldwide and more than 4 million people
have died
of covet 19. and in this graph here on
the slide you can see the number of
confirmed cases
per week actually in which part of the
world
from the beginning of the pandemic to
july 2021
and on the left you can also see the
total number of cases per region
so let's look at the causative agent of
these two diseases
the seasonal flu is caused by influenza
a and b
viruses and these viruses belong to the
orthomic severity
family of rna viruses there are in fact
four types of influenza viruses the a b
c and d but the a and b are responsible
for the seasonal flu infections
influences the infections usually uh
cause mild illness and are not
thought to be involved in the seasonal
flu epidemic
and influenza d viruses are not known to
infect
humans and the genome of the influence
of viruses is rna
and it consists of eight negative single
strands so it's it's a
segmented genome um and you can see here
in this image
um the structure of the viral particles
and the two proteins on the surface of
these implants of viruses are
particularly important
and these are the hemagglutinin shown
here are in blue
and neuraminidase shown in red and
hemoglobin in binds to the cellic acid
which ears as a receptor on the surface
of respiratory epithelial cells and
enables the virus to enter the cells
while neuraminidase on the other hand
facilitates the release of the viral
particles from the infected cells
and their spread and normally a person
would develop
antibodies against these surface
proteins which are also referred to as
antigens
now the kovic 19 is caused by thyroscopy
ii
and while sarskov2 is also an rna virus
like the implants of viruses it belongs
to a different family of corona virida
and
the genome of the ion sars cova2 is not
segmented so it is actually a single
a positive strand of rna and in this
case there is only one strain of the
virus with different viral variants
and if we look at the structure of the
viral particle we can see that the
surface of the virus is covered mainly
in the s-protein or the so-called spike
protein
which actually binds to the apa2
receptor on human cells
and enables the virus to infect them
so um as i said in the previous slide
the stars cover two viruses the single
strain while influenza a and b
also have virus substance and in case of
influenza a
the substance are defined by the two
surface proteins that i already
mentioned which are the
neuraminidase and the hemoglutinin and
there are uh in fact 11 types of
neuraminides and 18 types of hemoglobin
and potentially this means we could have
a 198
types of implants a viruses but only 131
have been detected in nature so far
and the currently circulating subtypes
of influenza a
are the h1n1 and the h3
m2 and the h1n1 is related to the actual
2009 swine flu
pandemic on the other hand the influenza
b
virus has two lineages which are
referred to as the yamagata and
pictorial image
and normally displays a slower change
of genetic and this antigenic features
compared to
influenza a so several studies have
shown that actually influenza p
can cause equally severe disease um as
uh influenza a but you know if we look
what is the significance
of the flu a and blue b differentiation
so we must mention that you know both of
the types have the potential to
cause severe disease and in principle
the patient treatment is is similar for
both
um however of course for informing
vaccine design
assessing the antigenic drift and shifts
and assessing the impact on different
um of different implants of viruses and
various populations
groups is of course very important and
the current
seasonal implant says the mix of the
influenza a
h1n1 influenza a h3n2
and the two above mentioned b lineages
so the yamagata and and victoria and you
can see here in this graph
um the surveillance data for the
previous five years in the u.s
and the percentages of each of the
contributing
implants subtypes per year which you can
see that it quite
varies right so sometimes in the
beginning of the pandemic there is more
of
influencer b later on more influencer a
or vice versa and so on
so uh let's look at how the seasonal flu
and covet 19 are transmitted
and how does the incubation time and
clinical presentation compare
so both flue and covet 19 are easily
transmitted through direct contact and
droplets but also indirect spread you
know if you
touch a surface that has been
contaminated and then the mouth and nose
and so on uh but covet 19 means
considered to be more contagious and
also
linked to more super spreader events now
the person infected with the virus um
is usually uh contagious one day before
the onset of symptoms and up to one week
after the symptoms start in case of flu
uh but in case of cold one can be
infectious two days before the
symptoms appear and at least ten days um
later so in fact people are contagious
over longer periods of time in case of
covet
now the symptom onset usually occurs in
case of flu in one to four days upon
infection
whereas um for call with the incubation
can take
up to 14 days and one thing that both
viruses have in common is that infected
people can be asymptomatic
or have mild moderate or severe disease
um so once a patient gets symptoms of a
respiratory illness how do we know uh
is it covered or is it flu and the fact
is that copit19
and flu cannot be differentiated based
on symptoms only
so if we look at the clinical
presentation usually a patient will have
fever or chills coughs sore throat runny
nose um
and so on and sometimes in children also
vomiting and diarrhea
but these symptoms are common for both
diseases
and of course there are some differences
so for example in kovis 19
patients have reported loss or change in
taste of smell we also
often have cytokine storm and sometimes
also
blood clots or rarely multi-system
inflammatory syndrome
can be found in children
on the other hand patients suffering
from flu can more often get
a secondary bacterial infection and the
younger children
are at higher risk of complications in
case of
flu than in case of covid
now a proportion of patients will
develop a severe disease
in in both
and and flu infections um and the severe
disease is usually characterized by
pneumonia the acute respiratory distress
syndrome and then
myocarditis etc and it can of course
always accelerate the underlying
condition that a person
might have and the people who are at
high risk are of course the people 65
years and older in both cases or people
with
chronic conditions so the fact of the
matter is that if one wants to
differentiate whether a patient
presenting with these symptoms has flu
or influenza
testing needs to be performed in order
to um
confirm the diagnosis and
the cdc has developed recommendations on
testing strategy
when uh starts cova2 and implants are
called circulating
so basically if a patient comes in with
symptoms of an acute respiratory illness
and the patient requires hospitalization
or in the residence of a nursing home
for example
it is recommended that the multiplex um
pcr-based essay
for implants a and b and stars cover 2
is performed
of course if available and the viruses
can be also tested individually but the
multiplex tests will offer the
the faster result and if the patients do
not require hospitalization it is
recommended they get
tested by pcr for stars cov2 and then
tested for influenza also either as a
single test or in a multiplex essay if
available if the results will influence
the clinical management
or steps taken to control the infection
spread
but what is very important to remember
and it's particularly highlighted in the
cbc testing recommendations
is that the co-infections of influenza
and thyroscopy ii can
occur and that if we do a single test
for covid first and it is for example
positive that does not automatically
exclude implant same section
in the same individual and vice versa so
this is the exact reason why the
multiplex testing is recommended
especially for example in hospitalized
patients or nursing home residents
because we also want to prevent the
cross infection in these settings
as patients having clothing only for
example must be separated from patients
suffering from co-infections
so um in case so if we look at the
treatment
in cases of mild illness for both cold
and flu the treatment is mainly focused
on symptom management
so includes bad rest isolation avoiding
contact with other people
and in cases with severe disease or in
people at high risk of complications
um supported medical care is given to
manage symptoms and and complications
um however treatment strategies in other
cases are different
for covet and for flu um so if we look
at the treatments for
covalent so outpatients that are at high
risk of disease progression with covet
19
can receive the anti-terrorism two
monoclonal antibodies
and in hospital hospitalized cases on
supplemental oxygen
remdevier dexamethasone or both agents
together
are given in patients who require oxygen
delivery through a high
flow device or ventilation in addition
to dexa
methazone the um varicity
or totilitsumab are applied and the
treatment decision
for covid19 does not depend on the viral
variant with which the patient
is infected in cases with flu
antiviral drugs have been shown to have
the best clinical benefit if given in
the first 48 hours of the symptom onset
and this is an additional reason why
testing that can enable a quick and
precise result is essential
there are several approved drugs for
pool such as for example the
neuraminidase inhibitors
these are the uh also tamivir sanamivir
peramivir um but also there is um
a drug that acts as the inhibitor of
polymerase acidic endonuclease which is
the pyloxibus
and in addition of course antibiotics
are prescribed
for secondary bacterial infections and
again the virus type or subtype
um does not influence the treatment
decision
so even though uh clinically based on
symptoms only
uh the two diseases are very similar the
clinical management of patients is very
different and correct diagnosis is very
important
in order to um achieve better outcomes
so um i have already mentioned that both
influenza and sarcoma ii
are rna viruses and you know we know
that rna viruses
mutate at a certain rate um
and in the case of influenza virus there
are two types of changes that are
happening
so this is the so-called antigenic drift
which represents minor changes to the
genome that happen
all the time but there is also the
antigenic shift which usually happens
when one segment
of this genome is replaced by a segment
from a different
influenza virus because i've i've
already shown that
the genome of the influenza virus is
segmented
so what can happen is that you know if
the
animal gets for example infected with
two different strains
they can combine and give rise to um flu
to strains that cause and the flu
pandemics and as only influenza a
viruses have these animal reservoirs
they are the only ones that can
give rise to um pandemics and you know
we know that there were three major flu
pandemics in the 20th century
and then the latest one in 2009
where uh the segments from
the flu viruses of the north american
swine the eurasian swine human and bird
flu were combined
we generated the a h1n1 pdm09 virus
which is also
still circulating and on the other hand
the starscope 2 virus accumulates
mutations in its genome
most of which are affecting the s
protein which is the
surface protein as i already mentioned
and the emerging variants that contain
particular sets of mutations are then
classified based on the risk they pose
to the public health and variance of
interest
variance of concern or variance of high
consequence
and at the moment we have five variants
of concern circulating which are
referred to as the alpha beta gamma and
delta
and in addition there is also the alpha
variant with the e484k
mutation which is linked to immune
escape
so how do we observe
yeah so how do we prevent the spread
of the covet and and flu so in both
cases the personal protective measures
are recommended including
of course hand washing avoiding uh to
touch your face or nose or mouth
avoiding contact with infected
individuals
um and during the kovic 19 pandemic
countries have implemented additional
strict public health
measures uh prior to the availability of
the vaccines
which included also social distancing or
travel bans
um etc and you know of course
the major role in preventing the disease
um
are the vaccination and for flu
the annual vaccination is recommended
for
risk groups and as we have seen in the
previous slide the virus mutates and
different crop types may be present each
year
and so the flu vaccines are annually
updated based on the surveillance data
on influenza viruses in the previous flu
season
and normally because sometimes it can
happen that this is not the best
predictor of which subtypes will be
circulating next year
the flu vaccine efficacy um is in
reducing the risk of low illness can
vary
uh between 40 and 60
and we have several fdi approved
vaccines for example most commonly
the quadrivalent vaccines are given
which are designed against
a h1n1 a h3n2
and the two um the lineages
on the other hand the kovic 19 vaccines
have been developed in record time in
2020 and there are currently three
different vaccines that have been
authorized by the fda for the use under
the
eu a and current recommendation is to
vaccinate everyone 12 years or older
and the vaccine are based either on rna
technology or on viral vectors and
although we
we also know that the stars of two virus
mutates it is still unclear whether
the updates to the vaccines will be
needed um
due to this novel emerging viral
variants that might
um you know show immune escape
and you know several currently
circulating variants are associated with
slightly reduced efficacy of the
currently available vaccines
uh but so far it is considered that the
vaccine efficacy
is quite high uh
now besides the covet and flu there are
of course
other respiratory viruses which can
cause
similar symptoms and today i would just
like to mention
in addition to these two we just
discussed the respiratory synthetic
virus
or the rsv as this is one of the leading
causes of respiratory disease globally
and it also shows seasonal activity
which is similar to flu
in autumn and winter months and the
symptoms are usually
also runny nose cough loss of appetite
fever and pneumonia can also
develop in cases with the severe disease
the risk groups for severe disease in
case of rsv are young
infants but also older adults or
people with chronic diseases or weak
immune systems
and rsv is estimated to lead to around
60 000
hospitalizations in kids younger than
five
and more than 170 000 hospitalization in
adults over 65 years of age annually
and the treatment in this case focused
on symptom management
while the vaccine for example for rsv
are in development
and i would like to show you now some of
the surveillance data
which here in this graph is shown as
data from the european union
but looks rather similar for most of the
northern hemisphere
um and on the upper panel you can see
the seasonal activity of the rsv virus
with um
peaks of in the last what is this seven
years
and you can see that the peak of the
infections usually happens in either
week one of the year
or the last weeks um in the years
while on the other hand if we look at
the seasonal activity
of influenza we can see that it is
active in the same
period of the year so what is referred
to the
flu season but the peak of infection
varies
usually from december to march and for
example in the last 12 years you can see
that the peak was most often seen in
weeks
five to seven um so in in february
and what i want to bring your attention
to is that if you look
at the last year
during the clovis 19 pandemic the data
initially showed
there there were almost no cases or very
few cases of flu
or rsv during the usual flu season
but then at around week 11 or 13 of 2021
there has been a spike in rsv
and and flu infections which is not a
typical time when these infections occur
and this timing will be important for
what i will show later in the talk
so as i said the kovic 19 vaccination is
progressing worldwide and
you know while some countries like the
us or the uk
um and so on have managed to fully
vaccinate almost 50
or even more of the population worldwide
only
25 of the people have received a single
dose and
only half of those have been actually
fully vaccinated
but of course you know if we look at the
public health measures frequency which
is shown in these graphs
the dark blue colors corresponds to high
stringency meaning
social distancing travel dance mask
wearing etc
and you can see that for example uh
beginning of february this year
most of the countries were still
implementing a very strict
public health measures but over the
period
from you know end of february and so on
most of the countries started to ease
these restrictions
and that was exactly um that corresponds
with the
timing to the peak of cases and poo and
our suite that i have shown to you a
couple of slides earlier
so it is clear that all the public
health measures that were put in place
for kobit 19 were very efficient in
preventing the spread
also other respiratory viruses like flu
or rsv
but what we are looking at now is as the
restrictions
ease it is expected that the certain
cases of flu and rsv
might occur as we have already seen in
some parts of the world
and you know in fact the academy of
medical sciences in the uk
and also the world health organization
have published reports
looking ahead to winter 2021 2022
and beyond where they state that a
higher activity on
of influenza and rsv viruses is
anticipated
and the easing of social distancing and
other measures
may lead to a surge of infections
and in addition we should also take into
the consideration that the population
overall now has a decreased immunity
to these viruses because there was no
exposure to them in the previous year
and that also we are looking at the
higher risk of
influenza vaccine mismatch for the
upcoming season because now we have very
limited data available
for the influenza strains that were
circulating
in the previous season for vaccine
design
and i would like to conclude my talk
with the two statements on testing
recommendations coming from the european
cdc
and the academy of medical sciences um
in the uk so what they've stated is that
all patients with acute respiratory
symptoms in hospitals and other health
care settings and all specimens from
sentinel primary care surveillance
should be tested for both starscope 2
and influenza during the influenza
season
to monitor the incidence and trends over
time
and that given the overlapping symptoms
routine multi-pathogen testings for
start cover 2 influenza and possibly
other respiratory infections
is important for surveillance treatment
decisions such as timely use of
antivirals for
influenza minimizing ventilation times
and avoiding and reducing rates of
transmission and they
strongly support the multiplex testing
and with this i would like to conclude
and thank you for your attention and i'm
happy to hand over to peter friber
who will present the testing solutions
that thermo fisher has developed to
enable the laboratory
professionals to meet the challenges of
the upcoming blue season
thank you
thank you chair enough for this
excellent and very informative
presentation
we just learned that covet-19 an
influenza infection
cannot be differentiated based on
clinical symptoms alone
and that that a diagnostic test is
required to confirm the diagnosis
in the next part of this webinar i want
to introduce you to the tag pass covert
19 fluid flu b
combo kit which which is for individual
diagnostic use
authorized under the emergency use
authorization by the fda
this stuckpass covert 19 flow a flu b
combo kit
can detect and differentiate between sas
corner virus 2
influenza a and influenza b in the same
sample
i want to start my presentation with
giving you a very brief introduction to
the company thermo fisher scientific
and our response to covet 19. i then
want to focus on the tag pasco with 19
fluid fluid combo kit i will want to
introduce you
to the kit to the workflow to the
turnaround time
and to the performance of our kit at the
very end i want to address a researcher
in the audience
by giving you by giving you a very brief
introduction to our attackman
sas corner wires 2 fluid br3
rtpcrsa this essay is for research use
only
and it can detect sas coronavirus 2 flu
ab and
r3
vermo fission scientific is a global
leader in covit 19 testing
over 50 percent of covet 19 testing
performed
is using thermo fischer technology
when covet 19 crisis hit beginning of
last year
we immediately upscaled production of
our covert 19 combo quest
and we were able to we are able to
manufacture over 20 million covert 19
tests per week
as thermo fisher scientific is
vertically integrated
we can also offer a secured supply chain
to reliable meet
the global testing demand of all our
customers
not only for the covet 19 tests but also
for consumables and instruments
we also do offer a 24 7 service and
support
on our tests our consumables instruments
and software
and with that i want to introduce you to
the tagpass covert 19 flo aflub combo
kit
again this kit is for in visual
diagnostic use authorized under the
emergency use authorization by the fda
the tagpath covert 19 fluid flow b combo
kit
is an all-in-one real-time pcr
respiratory test
that in a single sample can detect and
differentiate
between sas corner virus ii influenza a
and influenza b
it can also detect a multiple infection
in the same sample
it utilizes the ms2 bacteriophage as an
externally added process control in each
specimen
it is affordable and scalable it
utilizes a multi-target assay design
that helps to compensate for merging
source corner virus two mutations
and variants and it also comes with our
pathogen interpretive software
that will automatically validate each
test run
and prepare a report for each specimen
this reduces the risk of user
interpretation error
this slide gives you an overview of the
authorized workflow for the tagpass
covet 19 fluid fluid combo kit
i will go into each of the steps in more
detail in the following slides
a lab will first receive the samples the
samples then
are prepared or the viral rna is
extracted using our automated kingfisher
flex purification system
once the wire rna is extracted the
real-time pci is prepared
using the tagpass covert 19 fluid flow b
combo kit
in combination with the tagpass one step
multiplex master mix
and it is run on either the 7500 fast dx
or the quant studio 5 and 1960 format
once the pcr run has completed our
pathogen interpretive software will
automatically
interpret this results and prepare a
report for each specimen
the sample types that are supported by
our
assay are either nasopharyngeal swabs or
anterior nasal swabs
and once the lab has received the
samples the samples are prepared using
our magmax viral pathogen 2 nucleate
asset isolation kit
in combination with our automated
kingfisher flex purification system
using a 96 deep well head and a deep
well heat block
once the samples are extracted and
the rtpcr is prepared using the tagpath
covert 19 flow a fluid combo kit in
combination with the tagpass one step
multiplex master mix on a 96 web plate
and it is run on either the 7500 fast
dx return pcr system or the quant studio
5 real-time pcr system
in 96 configuration
and again once the pcr run has completed
our pathogen interpretive software will
automatically interpret the results
it will also automatically perform a
quality control for all controls on the
plate
and for each run a user has to include a
positive control
and a negative control and each sample
also includes the ms2 bacteriophage
control that was externally added
the interpretive software will generate
an interpretive report for each of the
specimen
and it also allows to export the results
so it can be integrated into your
laboratory into information
system
the turnaround time for the essay is
shown on this slide
it takes about three hours to run up to
94 samples on a 96
plate again two samples or two wells are
dedicated to the positive
and the negative control it takes about
45 minutes for a laboratory to receive
up to 94 samples
sample prep carried out by the
kingfisher flag system
takes 25 minutes for a 96 volt plate
to prepare the pcr takes approximately
30 minutes
running time of the pci is 82 minutes
and the report is available with our
pathogen interpretive software in less
than five minutes
so the overall turnaround time is about
three hours
in case that the next flu season will be
a more severe flu
season it may become necessary for a
laboratory to increase
the throughput of sample testing our
essay or
workflow is designed to allow increasing
samples throughput
if a laboratory utilizes multiple
instruments
what is shown on this slide is an
example where a laboratory uses one
kingfisher flags
two rtpcr systems and two employees per
shift
and that allows testing of up to 2 700
samples per day
this is achieved by staggering the
workflow which is
shown on this slide for example the
first employee will receive the first
batch
of samples once received the first batch
is transferred into the kingfisher flex
purification system
and once purified the second employee
will prepare the pcr
and place it in the pcr instrument this
is your
dark blue a workflow run on the left
hand side
once the first batch is in the
kingfisher flags purification system the
first employee
will start receiving the second batch of
samples and transferred to the
kingfisher flags
where the second employee will continue
once the samples are prepared and
prepare the pcr reaction
if a laboratory utilizes even more
instruments
the throughput can further upscale the
upscaled
i now want to introduce you to the
performance of the tag pass covert 19
through a flu b combo kit
i want to start with the limit of
detection we have expressed the limit of
detection either as
tcid50 pml which stands for tissue
culture infectious dose
50 or as genome copy equivalent pml or
short gce
pml for sas coronavirus 2 the limit of
detection
is 100 genome copy equivalents per
milliliter
for influencer a it's between 200 and
500 gce per ml
depending on the strain that is tested
for influencer b it's between 500 and
1000
gce pml again depending on which strain
is tested
the multiplex asset attacks are
cornervirus2 it detects fluid
subtypes h1n1 h3n2
and also less common subtypes including
h5n1
and h7n9 and it detects flu b strains
the major lineages the b tamagotta and b
victoria
we also wet lab tested in 10 different
influenza a
isolates five h1n1 and five h3n2 strains
we tested those isolates close to the
limit of detection
and the acid detected all samples tested
in a hundred percent
we also tested five different influenza
b
isolates including the both of the major
strains and additional
lineages and again we tested those
isolates
very close to the limit of detection and
we detected all
all tested samples a hundred percent of
the times
as this is a multiplex assay that can
detect three
uh two three different viruses
chronovirus two influenza a
and influenza b we also conducted
competitive
interference study to do so we
challenged our essay
by testing different combinations where
one virus has a very high viraltita
and the second virus has a very low
viral title close to the limit of
detection
on the amplification plot shown to the
left hand
of this slide uh you can see samples
where we that were
that had a very high influencer a
tighter and a very low sas corner virus
too tighter close to the limit of
detection
as you can see from the red
amplification plot influenza a with a
high titre
is amplified early on in the pcr
reaction and detected
even so influencer a is present in a
high title it does not interfere with
detection
of thus coronavirus ii as you can see by
the queen amplification
blood that is labeled co with low
the samples also detect the internal
extraction control
ms2 bacteriophage and influenza b which
is not present in the sample is not
detected
the amplification plot to the right hand
side of this slide
reflects samples where we had a high
title of influencer b
and a low title of sas corner of rs2
again very close to the limit of
detection
as you can see influencer b is detected
early on
during the amplification and despite the
height level of
influenza b present in the sample uh the
kit detects
source corner virus 2 even though it is
close to the limit of detection
it also detects ms2 bacteriophage the
control
in the sample it does not detect
influenza a which was not present in the
sample
we also performed a clinical study using
retrospective samples
as a comparator for source chronovirus 2
we used an eoa approved essay
for influenza a in influencer b we used
an fda
a cleared comparator
on this slide you can see the positive
percent agreement and the negative
percentage agreement
just as a reminder the positive percent
agreement reflects the percentage of
samples that tested positive
with the tag path covered 19 fluid flu b
combo kit
and positive with the comparator the
negative percentage agreement reflects
the percentage of samples
that tested negative for the tagpath
covert 19 fluid a flu b combo kit
and negative for the comparator as you
can see south corona voice 2
and influenza a have a positive percent
agreement of
96 percent influenza b has a positive
percentage agreement
of around 92 the negative percent
agreement
for south korean of rs2 is 100 and for
influencer a is close to 100
for influencer b the negative percent is
about 97
those percentages exceed the fda
agreement requirements and actually
demonstrate the excellent performance
of the tagpass covered 19 flow airflow b
combo kit
with that i want to summarize the
tagpass covered 19th fluid fluid combo
kit
targets last coronavius 2 influenza a
and
influenza b it can detect and
differentiate between all three viruses
it can also detect multiple viruses in
the same sample
it utilizes the ms2 bacterial phage as
an externally added process control
a positive control is included in the
kit the authorized sample types are
nasopharyngeal swabs and anterior nasal
swabs
sample prep is carried out using the
magmax viral puzzle gen 2 nougat asset
isolation kit
on our automated kingfisher flex
purification system
the pcr setup using the tagpass cover 19
flew a flu b combo kit
in combination with the tagpass one step
multiplex master mix
no rocks and the pcr is run on the 7500
fast dx
or the quant studio 5 and 96 well format
the turnaround time is about three hours
and the workflow is designed to allow
staggering of multiple batches
if a lab has additional qpcr instruments
available
our essay kit also comes with a pathogen
interpretive software
that will automatically validate each
run and prepare a report for each
specimen
the essay is authorized for individual
diagnostic use under the emergency use
authorization
by the fda
we currently offer this the tuckpass
covered 19 fluid fluid combo kit
as a kit for without a thousand
reactions
the kit includes all the primers and
probes for the pcr it includes the ms2
fetch control
it also includes the covert 19 influenza
a and influencer b
rna controls and a buffer to dilute the
rna controls
please visit thermofisher.com dash
covert or slash
coveted 19 flu to learn more about how
to order this essay
i also want to briefly introduce you to
our ab
platinum service plan
the ab platinum service plan supports
all our eoa
covert 19 assets and customers using
those assets
it supports the qpcr instruments and the
kingfisher
flex system we guarantee a 19
8 98 up time of course terms and
condition apply
the a b platinum offering includes a
qualification
service a priority techno technical
support
that is available to our customers 24
hours 7 days a week
365 days a year so yes that includes
weekends
it also also offers a rapid response
on-site response
a guaranteed next business day on site
response
it includes a training or two-hour
remote field application specialist
consultation
it includes all plant maintain
maintenance as required
it includes a comprehensive repair
coverage and a digital remote support
if you are interested in the ap platinum
support plan
please visit thermofisher.com
uptime
in the very last couple of slides i want
to introduce the researchers
in the audience to our multiplex reason
pcr kit for the detection of sas corner
wires 2
influenza and rsv this essay is for
research use only
and it is not for the use and diagnostic
procedures
the techmen's ascornovirus2flu a
flu abrsv rtp crsa is a real-time pcr
kit that is specifically designed
for pathogen detection research during
the overlap
overlap of the south corner rs2 crisis
with the flu season
it detects sas corona virus 2 in the
weak channel influenza a b
in the fam channel and rsv a b in the
abi
channel it does use an internal control
the ms2 bacteriophage
which is detected in the june channel
positive controls are commercially
available and the turnaround time is
between three to three and a half hours
we offer this kit in a thousand reaction
size
and even so it can be run on any qpcr
instrument
that supports above mentioned channels
we do recommend to run it on our 7500
fast
if you are interested to order this
sketch please visit visit
thermofisher.com slash covert 19 flu
ruo you can order the tachman sas corner
virus 2 flu a b
rsv rtp crs kit again in a thousand
reaction per unit
we also offer the tachman saskronovirus
2 flu ab
rsv rna control and a control dilution
buffer
and the tagpass one step rt qpcr master
mix
and with that i want to thank you and
open the q
a session
thank you yelena and peter for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is uh how does the workflow of
the copic 19
flu a flu b assay compared to the
workflow of the kovid 19 combo kit and i
think this question is for peter
but you all can decide how you would
like to answer
so if you are already using our tag
passcode 19
combo kit you've probably noticed that
the workflow and the turnaround time of
the tuckpass covered 19th floor a flu b
combo kit is very similar
so it will be very straightforward for
your laboratory to integrate the tag
pasco with 19 fluid flow b
combo kit for customers or
any interested parties who have not
previously experienced any of
our covert 19 asses we have
designed the covet 19 fluid flow b combo
kit in a way
that will allow easy integration into
your laboratory
we're using an automated extraction our
kingfisher flag
system to overcome any challenges of a
manual extraction
and we also offer the pathogen
interpretive software that will
automatically interpret
the test run results and create a report
for all specimens
included in the test
thank you peter our next question
how is the severity of the flu season
determined and what does it depend on
and this question is for you elena
thank you so much um yeah so usually the
the cdc has means in which the
the severity of the flu season is
classified
usually it is classified as low moderate
high or or very high
and um they assess the severity using
you know the
some of the data such as for example the
percentage of visits to outpatient
clinics
for an influencer like illness or
the rates of influenza associated uh
hospitalizations and of course the
percentage of that resulting from
pneumonia or influenza
that occurred during each season and
normally this severity um
depends on the virus subjects which are
circulating each year
um which we saw could be um rather
different depending on the
on the year
thank you and this next question is also
for you
how common are copic 19 and flu
co-infections
yeah um right so this is actually a
really difficult to say um there have
been several published reports
um so first of all for example at the
beginning of the pandemic
there was a scientific article published
in the journal of medical virality
and they have reported around 300
patients which were examined in buhari
in china
um really at the very beginning so this
was a period of january february 2020
um and at that time the pool was still
still circulating and they showed that
for example
around half of the patients actually had
the coin section
of sars kobe 2 with implants a and
around five to ten percent
of of them had a co-infection with
influenza b
um and actually you know first the the
earlier samples from january will mainly
are coinciding with b which was razer uh
replaced with the influenza a
but you know as the pandemic was
pronounced and
all these um measures were put in place
um such as
mask wearing social distancing and so on
there was like a very sharp drop
in in flue cases and um then the later
reports from like
patients um examined from march to may
for example
they reported very low rates of
co-infection
and you know with that being said you
know these are exactly the reasons why
there are all these concerns regarding
the upcoming flu season
um because you know we are now easing
this um
uh this restriction such as social
distancing or or the mask
is not necessary the traveling is
opening up in most countries
and you know it is expected that the
blue season might look different um from
what it looked like
last year and that you know we should be
um prepared
to perform multiplex testing for for
both viruses
and i i don't know if peter also wants
to comment on that
now i think you summarized this uh quite
well pretty well so
i don't have any further auditions
okay
thank you yelana and peter next question
is there a human rna detection control
included
to qualify a sample as adequately
collected
so sample collection is required to be
performed
by a professional by a professional so
it's not an
at-home or uh user selected uh
sample test uh with that we have decided
to utilize an ms2 external bacteriophage
control
so the fa does not include a human
target for to
for example to assess whether the sample
was
collected correctly my apologies for the
slightly stumbled answer
no worries thank you peter next question
here
would a combo real-time pcr kit be
possible to also decipher which
sars kobe 2 variant is present in a
sample
so the current fluid flow b covert 19
combo kit
does not allow to differentiate which
variant is present
however we do offer the tagman mutation
panel
that does allow to detect which
if there is a specific mutation present
and by using
combinations of mutation it does allow
to
detect variants in samples thank you
peter
our next question where can you find the
applied biosystems pathogen
interpretive software
for that i would like you to contact us
directly
our customer support and we will get
back to you
and provide the help needed
okay great thank you peter and looks
like we have time for one more question
how would you structurally set up your
lab for this testing
do you need unidirectional workflow with
different rooms please give as much
detail as possible
so as for any diagnostic testing
we do recommend a unidirectional
workflow and a separation of work spaces
uh and also to ensure that
laboratory material is not transferred
from one work
station to the next to really minimize
any potential risk of contamination
cross-contamination um so
different rooms would be one way to
handle this scenario
uh definitely a unidirectional workflow
because after pcr even so the plates are
sealed
you never want to go back to your
extraction or your receiving
station in your laboratory
but in the end this is up to the
laboratory to implement
based on their own risk management
appropriate measures
well thank you yelena and peter do
either of you have final comments for
our audience before we go
well i would like to thank everyone i'm
sorry go ahead
no please go ahead okay so
i would like to really thank everyone
for their attention
and um you know with the upcoming flu
season
of course we all hope it will all be as
much as possible but
you know we are here to uh prepare for
all the possible scenarios and it really
looks like as we are going now from a
pandemic into an endemic environment
that you know the covet and flu
uh multiplex testing um will become more
and more
relevant in the future thank you so much
i also want to thank everyone and really
uh emphasize that if you're interested
in our attack pass
covet 19 flew a flu b kit please with it
thermofisher.com
covet 19 flu to find more information
thank you again to our speakers dr
yelena feenstra and dr peter freeba
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye